boa tarde eu preciso primeiro agradecer
o convite também a parabenizar também
pela organização de palestras vêm
assistindo estão ótimas
e eu adorei um convite de ter poder
falar com vocês de algo que eu considero
que é uma das coisas mais importantes
que alguém pode fazer na vida
tanto pra ela mesma quanto para a
sociedade em que ela vive que a lei por
prazer em ler por prazer é algo que só
quem gosta mesmo só quem é é é fazer
essa experiência sabe o quanto é
engrandecedor quanto em poder a dor ter
essa leitura por prazer e se vocês se
alguém de vocês e tenho certeza que
alguém aqui ainda não gosta de ler por
prazer
talvez ainda não tenha encontrado o
estilo de livro certo para fazer é que
nem aquela história do príncipe que não
procurava desesperadamente por uma
pessoa que encaixar seu sapatinho de
cristal
você está nessa história até melhor do
que algumas pessoas mas é essa é uma
comparação que eu faço
as pessoas que não gostam ainda de ler e
eu tenho certeza que a partir de hoje
a gente vai tentar melhorar um pouco
essa relação de vocês com a leitura é
porque ainda não tenho certeza que ainda
não encontraram o xirú certo ou aquele
livro que canta de verdade e que vai
fazer com que vocês que irão chegar ao
final daquela história sem parar e vão
reclamar de alguém que atrapalhar vocês
essa esse o motivo porque as pessoas
podem não gostar de ler ainda ou
ainda não acharam o seu estilo livro
preferido tem diversas explicações mas
eu costumo contar uma historinha uma
historinha que ela pode ter dois finais
e que ela ela tenta resumir um pouco de
como seria a relação de uma pessoa
quando ela quer ler algo e ela é uma
criança uma pré adolescente
vou chamar nossa a nossa personagem de
camila camila ela dá não ainda não se
encantou tanto com a leitura mas ela
assistiu a uma série um filme sobre
vampiros
ela chegou a assistir aquela série esse
filme e adorou o tema dando aquela ficou
louca está procurando localmente achar
um livro sobre vampiros
o pai dela e pede pai me leva a uma
livraria porque uma amiguinha do colégio
disse que tem um livro muito legal sobre
vampiros thabo mbeki de vamos lá o pai
leva ela já a livraria da fox que eu uma
livraria muito legal aqui de belém e que
eu recomendo as pessoas a visitar para
chegar lá na livraria e encontra
fechamos vendedor de livros que um bom
uma boa livraria tem sempre um bom
vendedor de livros é e pergunta você
pode indicar um livro sobre vampiros
vinculado
ele pega vários e ela consegue separar
dois títulos que são mais destacados
é o vampiro bobo que é o das sacolas
aqui porque custo fecha a atenção de uma
eu fiz as contas e só é só uma maneira
de se expressar e um vampiro clássico
que é um drácula de bram stocker
ela pega os dois na frente e começa a
analisar qual dos dois ela vai gostar
e aí começa é é 12 finais alternativos
da nossa história primeiro final
alternativo é quando ela chega com o pai
e fala pai eu quero ler a saga
crepúsculo porque me identifiquei mais
com as personagens eu acho que os
personagens zé é sangue da escola eu sei
que tem uma série eu vou adorar esse
livro então eu quero comprar saga
crepúsculo esse livro aqui
o pai vai tudo bem minha filha respeito
à sua a sua decisão
vamos comprar o pai compra esse livro a
menina chega na casa dela camila devolve
o livro se apaixona por literatura de
vampiros e diz agora eu quero outro
e pra quem sabe se irá ele tem uma série
de outros livros e ela provavelmente vai
ler esses outros livros vai devorar los
e quando terminar essa série ela vai
olhar cego eu quero continuar lendo
vampiros porque agora posso ler outros
livros posso ler animais
posso lembrar o estoque posso ler livros
sobre os lobisomens por exemplo eu posso
ler literatura fantástica porque esse
tipo de livro pode ele tem uma um pé na
literatura fantástica e seu final
alternativo
conseguimos apaixonar a camila pela
literatura
o outro final alternativo pai eu
gostaria de levar o farnel crepúsculo o
pai diz a lucas que se está a acertar é
brincando comigo vai levar essa boca com
essa porcaria esse livro de vampiro bobo
você tem que não o clássico você tem que
levar um dois toques
você não pode ler esse tipo de livro que
a sua amiga lei porque isso não presta
você não pode ler esse tipo de livro
você tem que ler o clássico então vamos
levar e não me venha mais com conversa a
gente vai levar o vampiro clássico do
brasil tour
ela por amar muito o pai vai decidir
tudo bem para o respeito vamos lá vamos
levar você está
ela chega na casa dela como falei pra
vocês ela não tem muito ainda muita
bagagem literária ela pega o drácula
começa a lei quem já leu drácula sabe
que ele foi escrito num estilo é de
cartas né epistolar ele são os
personagens eles contam entre si a
história e iam e não é tão fácil assim é
uma literatura difícil
existem claro pessoas que são gênios da
literatura que essa pode até ser o caso
dela que vai pegar essa esse livro vai
destrinchar ele ele vai passar a divina
comédia depois né
mas como a gente está trabalhando com a
média aqui eu por exemplo não época não
era um gênio da literatura eu comecei
com esses não comecei com esses
clássicos mas como não estamos
trabalhando com a média ela não vai ter
facilidade para ler o drácula vai se
frustrar ainda colocou a leitura e vai
dizer assim poxa meu pai me obrigou a
esse livro não quero mais dele e é o
mínimo que vai acontecer é que essa mina
não vai gostar não quer uma lei de
vampiros não pode até procurar outros
tipos de livro mas esse tipo de vampiro
ela já se frustrou está traumatizada e
aí a gente tem o final do segundo
na segunda alternativa que é não
conseguimos apaixonar
a menina fazer ela se apaixonará por
literatura é uma pena mas a imposição
quando a gente impõe a alguém a gente
automaticamente faz com que a pessoa é
associa aquele prazer algo obrigatório
quando na verdade a gente precisa é pra
ler por prazer e gosto gostar daquilo
que está fazendo
a gente precisa se apaixonar amar os
livros é o que é no grego de ser uma
fila bíblia seria a bíblia filia o
amizade pelos livros
a filha que é o amor por algo que você
se sentir prazer em fazer algo e é e no
caso da nossa conversa hoje é só os
livros né
então é uma imposição ela é algo que
gera a obrigação
isso não é legal ea gente consegue ver
isso esses exemplos não apenas em casa
essa historinha da na caminhada com o
pai dela a gente vê isso também nas
escolas
a maneira como os alunos recebem os
livros os quais eles são obrigados a ler
as leituras obrigatórias aquelas
leituras pré vestibular ea gente recebe
aquela pressão uma pressão desesperadora
de ler tal livro eu é contra 11
algumas histórias de quando eu estudava
no colégio eu adorava ler eu sempre fui
apaixonado por literatura mas eu tinha
dificuldade para ler aqueles livros que
os o o vestibular e exigir ou aquele
aquele determinada série do colégio
exigia eu diria eu fazia questão de
concluir muito bem a disciplina de
literatura mas não era não era um desejo
eu eu me lembro que em alguns livros
como a senhora como o auto da barca do
inferno
são clássicos absolutos isso não se
discute mas que eles são indicados foram
pro garoto de primeiro ano com 15 e 16
anos
como eu falei pra vocês eu sou um gênio
da literatura e vou adorar mas se eu não
tiver essa facilidade
eu posso olhar para aqueles livros
identificar eles como algo que eu não
vou gostar e isso pode gerar pra mim
consequências é pro resto da minha vida
e é por isso que eu falo sempre para as
pessoas que eu sou um defensor
incansável da leitura de qualquer nível
que vocês quiserem ler qualquer
shiloh a gente pode é citar autoajuda e
eróticos biografias até bolo de remédio
se vocês quiserem ler é bom porque
quando eu falei pra vocês são essas
leituras iniciais de nós com crianças
quando adolescente e na chegada na fase
adulta são as leituras que a gente está
escolhendo é que vão fazer toda
diferença inclusive aquelas leituras
obrigatórias porque a gente sabe também
que nem todos os livros gente precisa
ler com prazer porque existem muito
diferente da gente precisa ler para
cumprir um estágio na nossa vida ou é
entender é uma disciplina na
universidade enfim
mas se eu já tenho toda essa estrutura
de leitura por prazer quando pega um
livro que eu preciso ler que é
necessário para cumprir uma estágio da
minha vida eu vou ler com mais
facilidade
eu sou eu sempre falo eu sou a favor de
qualquer estilo de literatura e e eu vou
tentar convencer vocês nessa nossa
conversa aqui e vocês também devem ser
defensores de qualquer estilo de
literatura se deve ler o que vocês
quiserem porque a gente tem aqui no
brasil uma um grande problema e esse
problema ele aparece vocês todas devem
reconhecer que é o índice de leitura já
a quantidade de leituras que as pessoas
fazem por ano
rapidamente pensa em aqui é quantos
livros vocês já leram em 2016 temos
agora cerca de quatro meses apenas em
e tem lembrar quantos livros vocês já
pegaram para ler e concluíram a leitura
em 2016
essa é uma reflexão que eu sempre peço
às pessoas fazerem porque é o brasil tem
índices muito baixos de eleitor por ano
e eu tô com base uma pesquisa chamada
retratos da leitura no brasil que em
2007 apontou que os brasileiros viam um
média 4.7 e livros por ano
infelizmente em 2013
essa média baixo para 4 ou seja 0,7
livro já saíram da lista dos brasileiros
detalhe essa lista ela leva em
consideração se vocês quiserem podem
pesquisar retratos da leitura no brasil
essa lista considera dois pontos que são
muito importantes
o primeiro é que nem todos decididos
eles são leitores vorazes edição é
também mistura um pouco de leituras
obrigatórias e outro ponto é que nesses
quatro livros por ano que o brasileiro
lê ô ô ô retratos da leitura no brasil
foi muito benevolente porque é o
brasileiro não precisa ler completamente
o livro ele precisa ler só até à metade
mais ou menos nos últimos três meses
ou seja se você nem concluiu a leitura e
você é te levou três meses para fazer
aquilo ele já considera que entra nessa
média de quatro por ano
isso daí é uma média muito baixa a gente
com ele até para o lado até para a
argentina que são
é um povo que 6 muito mais do que nós
cerca de três vezes mais do que nós
belém entre 11 e 12 livros japoneses
aqueles que mais lêem no mundo assim mas
conhecido ele em cerca de 30 livros por
ano
a gente aqui está com quatro livros e é
muito é isso é muito baixo é agora 11
pontos interessantes agente destacar é
que é normalmente as pessoas acham na
possui sudeste que a gente aqui no norte
e nordeste lê pouco
infelizmente no norte aqui nós vemos
realmente muito pouco a gente leva uma
média de dois pontos sete livros por ano
agora no nordeste a maior média 4.3
é esse é um problema que a gente
enfrenta no país
a gente é tem diversos fatores um deles
é o nafa alfabetismo outro de lesão
próximo estágio analfabetismo funcional
as pessoas sabem ler e escrever mas elas
têm dificuldade para ler mas tem
dificuldade para desenvolver a leitura é
e quanto retratos da leitura no brasil
começa a pesquisar os motivos que as
pessoas dão por não querer ler 50% das
pessoas dizem que elas não têm tempo
para ler
será que é verdade que as pessoas não
têm tempo para ler porque a gente vê
tantas vezes a pessoa simplesmente ela
quer fazer outra coisa e retratos da
leitura no brasil mostra também que a
leitura ela ocupa a singela posição do
sétimo lugar
ela ocupa a sétima posição na na lista
daquilo que o brasileiro gosta de fazer
mais um brasileiro gosta de ir a um show
assistir um filme sai com os amigos
tomar uma cerveja e lá pelo sétimo lugar
da leitura
o que eu quero dizer com isso falta de
tempo não é uma boa desculpa porque a
pessoa a pessoa chega um amigo chega com
outro fulano vamos tomar uma cerveja ali
no bar
vamos ele vai lá e vai ficar pelo menos
umas duas horas nesse bairro a leitura
se faz nesse tempo livre então se ela
prefere ir para um bar tom ela não tem
falta de tempo ela simplesmente preferem
fazer outras coisas uma outra desculpa
tem não tem paciência ou o livro é caro
alguém já ouviu isso não há livros são
caros mas usar o mesmo exemplo do bar da
cerveja
se a pessoa comprar 3 100 vídeos por 10
reais são 30 reais
tenho certeza absoluta que você se você
não quiser comprar um livro novo por
r$30 tudo bem mas existem em livrarias
de livros usados que você companheiros a
r$1 2 35 reais nível de bons então na
verdade o que o brasileiro enfrenta não
é falta de tempo é falta de interesse e
esse interesse
ele é muito estimulado por diversas é
pessoas diversos instrumentos que podem
surgir na vida da neci leitor desse
leitor em potencial
a primeira delas que mais influenciam os
leitores a lei é o professor ou
professora que se a gente leva em
consideração que os alunos como são
crianças passam grande parte do seu dia
numa escola é porque eles é só foi uma
influência forte dos pais e 43% das
pessoas que mais influenciaram os
leitores a lei está a mãe ou responsável
do sexo feminino ou dele logo depois do
pai
eu tive uma um privilégio muito grande
de
ter pais de incentivar a leitura
eu eu me lembro de de história de que eu
era apaixonado por leitura desde pequeno
e meu pai que ele fazia comigo meu pai
minha mãe e quando chegava a uma
livraria eu escolhia livros digamos
pegavam quero esse dez livros
o meu pai olhava os dez livros ele sabia
que tinha certeza que não ia lei todos
aqueles livros eu ia ler metade mas o
que ele fazia tudo meu filho pega esses
livros a gente leva hoje vão ficar em
casa
eu passava o final de semana inteiro
está vigiado com aqueles livros a semana
toda brincava com meus amigos dizendo eu
lhe tal livro eu li eu escutei tal
história e isso me fez gostar demais da
leitura
isso me fez é é sempre pensar que o
sábado quero dia que meu pai me levava
pra livraria era o melhor dia da semana
porque podia chegar aí vai escolher
qualquer livro e ele ia me dar
claro que ele tinha um cuidado sim de de
orientar uma leitura ou outra pra mim
mas ele nunca e obrigou a fazer a a
leitura que gostaria e meu pai é
escritor
ele tinha todos os motivos na cabeça
prováveis de dizer que eu não deveria
ler o livro bobinhos deveria ler
leituras obrigatórias os passos
ele nunca fez isso isso é um privilégio
tenho então uma uma sugestão que eu dou
a todos vocês nunca deixe uma criança
nunca sem livros nas mãos nunca ninguém
em um nível para uma criança qualquer
livro que ela quiser claro tomando
cuidado de das faixas etárias devem ser
tomados claro mas não façam não nega em
livros pra elas sempre entregue a isso
os livros três precisam
o que você aprende amando os livros que
o que eu aprendi nada na minha vida né
eu perdi três coisas uma delas foi que a
leitura me trazem empatia eu consigo
entender que o que o outro sente porque
eu consigo experimentar o que aquele
personagem ou aquele autor passou eu
consigo entender que o outro necessita
de algo eu consigo é lembrar que ele
também é um ser humano e isso é empatia
foi nas mesmas coisas que a literatura
me ensinou o amor pelos livros
o segundo é o respeito entender que o
outro tem seus próprios gostos e ele tem
ele é o que o modismo fala é que todos
querem estão em busca da felicidade
então todos nós queremos ser felizes e
tenho que respeitar o seu desejo de ser
feliz
esse o seu desejo de ser feliz em ler um
livro na saga crepúsculo e harry potter
seja feliz ea terceira coisa é o carinho
eu separei esses 26 duas imagens porque
esse pessoal esse ator danny trejo rio
ele faz de filmes é sempre muito
violentos muito muito sangue não lembre
se com uma manchete e ele já que ele é
sempre na época do natal e de participar
de um programa de televisão sempre lendo
para crianças
isso aí a gente consegue com a leitura a
gente consegue ter carinho pelo outro e
pelos livros e daí pra finalizar eu eu
eu eu devo imaginar que algum de vocês
devem se perguntar o que eu apresentei
disse que o brasil é um país que lê
pouco então por que eu desse dia criar
uma editora num país que lê tão pouco e
a resposta que posso dar pra vocês é que
como eu sou apaixonado por livros
eu me sinto na obrigação
de fazer com que vocês e todos os
leitores vejam e encontrem aquele livro
pelo qual vocês vão se apaixonar
então devo fazer se meu trabalho é de
modo que vocês é é alcance esse amor
também que você experimenta em o que eu
sinto pelos livros que é o amor eo
prazer que pareça essa frase do dov que
ele tenta definir daqui somos todos
felizes do que os outros no guidão
primeiro nossos pais depois aqueles que
nos séculos a literatura abre ao
infinito essa possibilidade de interação
com os outros e por isso nos enriquece
infinitamente muito obrigado